okay could I could I get more specifics
because this is just very broad specific
and what like what what exactly you
would do every day I guess away
and you said like you did this stuff at
like wifey things at girlfriend oh yeah
what does that mean no cook I clean you
know I'd wake up make the bed if do you
think do you think a man paying for a
date is doing husband things at
boyfriend prices
I'm paying for a date is that doing
husband things at boyfriend prices
because a lot of times I think like we
say we cooked we cleaned and that's
that's wifey things at girlfriend prices
but then they protect and provide
possibly yeah okay so you think a man
shouldn't pay
unless he marries you no I don't think
that but if you know I'm choosing to
cook and clean you can choose to pay if
you want to pay if you don't want to pay
I'm not getting onto you about that same
way if I don't cook you're not going to
get onto me about that